MARTIN: Hi, Kevin.
KEVIN: Hi, Martin.
MARTIN: I heard you
work for a car sharing
service called GreenMobility,
and the company
is using serverless.
KEVIN: Yeah, our dev
team is really productive
thanks to serverless computing.
MARTIN: Oh, maybe you
could share some tips
on how to use serverless
to get your developers more
productive?
KEVIN: I would be happy to.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARTIN: So, Kevin, GreenMobility
is a car sharing service?
KEVIN: Yes.
We run a car sharing platform
in seven European cities.
We have hundreds of cars.
And people use them for
[INAUDIBLE] trips every day.
We have about 100
employees, with headquarters
in Copenhagen. And we are listed
on the NASDAQ main market.
MARTIN: Oh, cool.
I guess many people want to
use cars, but not necessarily
own cars these days.
KEVIN: Yeah.
Like, more and more people
want to live in cities.
And they're interested
in sustainability.
And they also prefer sharing
things rather than owning them.
MARTIN: Oh, right.
So what kind of data
processing does the company
need to make this
car sharing happen?
KEVIN: We've processed
hundreds of thousands
of events every day.
Trips, stars, car
moves, a car trip ends.
We could have built
this infrastructure
for handling these events
with virtual machines.
But there would have
been a lot of work.
Instead, we went
with serverless.
It make this much easier.
MARTIN: Oh, cool.
I love serverless.
Where do you store
these events, Kevin?
KEVIN: We store
them in Firestore.
We also have a Cloud SQL
database for other data.
But we got better data
writing performance
at a lower cost with Firestore.
And Firestore is serverless,
which means less iteration
work for us.
So we will have SQL
and NoSQL databases.
MARTIN: Ah, got it.
Machine learning
is hot right now.
Are you doing that, too?
KEVIN: We're working on it.
We like to predict where
cars will be needed,
so we can put cars in
those places ahead of time.
Our plan is to export the
Firestore database to BigQuery
every night.
Then we can run
reports in BigQuery
and run BigQuery ML to do the
machine learning on the data.
MARTIN: Oh.
Are there any other factors that
made you go with serverless?
KEVIN: We also
have uneven demand.
More people are driving
during the day than at night.
So it would be inefficient
to scale our computing
and databases up
and down ourselves.
But Cloud Run and Firestore
do it automatically.
MARTIN: Ah.
Why did you pick Cloud
Run specifically, Kevin?
KEVIN: We really
like containers.
And Cloud Run lets
us host containers
without having to
worry about the server.
If a server is acting up,
Google fixes the problem
and we don't have to.
Also, we like the billing model.
We pay for container time,
even if the container
is handling multiple
requests at the same time.
MARTIN: You mentioned billing.
How much are you actually
paying for Cloud Run?
KEVIN: Our Cloud Run
bill has been growing.
So I'm keeping an eye on it.
Last month, we handled
six million requests.
With Cloud Run, we paid
2,000 Danish kroner,
and that's about
$320 US dollars.
MARTIN: Not too bad.
How do you deploy your
containers to Cloud Run?
KEVIN: When a [INAUDIBLE]
merges into the main branch
in our source control, a
trigger ultimately builds
and deploys the container
to our staging environment.
And that happens
about 50 times a week.
And when we're done testing
that particular release,
we manually run a script
to deploy that container
to our production environment.
And that also happens
about 50 times per week.
MARTIN: Are you
building the containers
on one of your machines,
or up in the cloud?
KEVIN: How are we using cloud
built-in Google Cloud platform?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Our build was recently getting
slow and taking 15 minutes.
But it was easy for us to
change that machine type
in one line on our
cloud builder YAML,
which reduced the build
time to five minutes only.
MARTIN: Oh, nice.
So, when you do 50 deployments
per week, that's a lot.
How do you keep these
deployments straight.
KEVIN: We're big fans of
immutable deployments.
When Cloud Run
deploys a container,
you can't tweak settings
and environment variables.
Instead, you do
a new deployment.
So immutable deployments
prevent drift
in our production environment.
MARTIN: Ah, that
makes sense, Kevin.
I'd love to hear
more about that.
Maybe you could tell us more
details in the next episode?
KEVIN: Sounds good.
MARTIN: And thank you,
everyone, for watching.
If you have questions
for Kevin or me,
please add them in the comments.
Also, this episode was a
little different from others
in the Serverless
Expeditions series.
Please let us know if
you found it useful.
Until next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]